allez mon gars sachez que ce week end
une idée en regardant sur le net des
mecs sauter sur des normes coussins
gonflables
moi je l'avais déjà fait je l'avais déjà
fait j'avais fait une chute de 25 mètres
comme ça pour le kiff pas franchement
peine cinq campagnes
jamais de la vie je vous jure que c'est
vrai on la fmsq en extérieur on l'a pas
fait à l'intérieur wii est là et bien on
va jouer à big flo et oli
c'est parti xo 10
xo
oui
xo et au lycée très simple on va faire
comme dans les amours je vais poser des
questions poser des questions je vais
demander des questions à big flo qui va
devoir répondre de génie technique puis
sur hbo lit au lit mais non on fait le
contraire en plus ces fléaux qui là bas
c'est flou qui s'opèrent on a échangé
parce que j'ai trop peur et c'est ça je
sais c'est ça la c3 est ce qu'on peut
avoir s'il vous plaît alors roulé ces
olim wavre et je sais il olivos qu'au
départ c'était lui qui devait sauter oui
je sais après vous avez changé c'est
pour ça donc je sais mon orly tu vas tu
vas monter de plus en plus haut on va
poser des questions à ton frère sur toi
je t'avais ça les aide pas mal on fera
monter et la passerelle de plus en plus
tu dois faire un saut il n'y a même pas
un ya rien du tout tu dois sauter non je
crois que c est mettre à chaque fois
exactement merci je vois tu connais
mieux les méchantes moissac ya eu
question tu pourras aller jusqu'à 8
mètres d'un stop stress là d'accord au
les intentions vous avez 45 secondes tu
dois répondre au moins je te dis à
toutes les questions
allez vous attend c'est facile à c'est
un truc de rapidité
ouais non même pas on enlève la rapidité
c'est qu'on va faire comme ça à est-ce
que tu connais la partie du corps de son
frère qui le complexe le plus
oui sa calvitie oui c'est bon ça je
connais son insulte préférées [ __ ] oui
est-ce que tu connais la première chose
qu'au lit regarde chez une fille les
fesses je dis pas non c'est faux non
c'est ses yeux est à ses yeux le projet
procurera tu connais l'artiste kilkee
fonds secrets on se crée ouais la
chanteur mais c'est un chanteur
animateur patrick sébastien bien sûre et
le truc le plus fou qu'il a dédicacé à
une jambe en moi oui il est trop fort
10/06 ouf ça le truc louche café qui l'a
fait par amour il aime personnes
est ce que tu a rappelé qu'il a fait
part à pau entre tous non j'ai pas
souvenir faire les frères avaient poussé
les nuls
ban est resté et franchement c'est non
le train j'ai fait tout le gratin maison
sutra voilà c'est ça ou de ouf
il a fait toulouse bordeaux en train
aller retour pour quelques heures de
zaire nez ses deux heures on irait qui
m'a dit j'ai fait toulouse hawaï est là
l'april est le sujet sur lequel vous
n'êtes jamais d'accord allez les filles
non à part ça l'argent non qu'est ce
qu'il a pu dire
là je sais pas là j'ai fait mon appareil
les faits les normands à y paraît car
oui frères quoi attention ça va jouer
sur cette question est-ce que tu connais
la durée exacte de la plus longue
relation qu'il a eu avec une meuf
il faut exactement ces trois ans
non ces deux ans et sept mois
on va le monter à lui m
[Applaudissements]
le mois bah quoi que ce soit dans tous
les cas on est apte à perdre pas mal de
valloire a mené le même type de sac j'ai
monté mon sérieux tu m'entends baroin je
suis pas bien fringants futur c'est vrai
mais voilà on s'en rend pas compte je
vous jure que ses pairs est-ce que vous
pouvez mettre une caméra d'or est monté
encore mais devant des milliers de
disques solos mois et vous m'attendais
vous voyez attends attends je vais te
dire je te laisse juste un truc tu ne
veux pas c'est ce qu'ont pas monter
encore un peu ce qu'on peut faire un
truc sinon non sire il adore tant qu'une
solution quoi all i way jusqu'à août est
prêt pour réussir dans la musique
vas-y a demandé j'ai une solution
matthieu delormeau n'a pas encore son
billet près
[Applaudissements]
à toi
d'attenté
[Applaudissements]
maître de l'enfant n'est pas encore
qualifié pour la la belle n'a pas oublié
non plus n'ont alors vous êtes merdy
vous le faites
ne tombez pas sur le nez vous avez rêve
est-ce que suis-je il saute ouej il
saute
si tu gagnes tombiez pour la laponie
quasiment gilles mathieu cgt
non mais moi je peux pas mais là bas tu
es ce que tu veux bien essayer
gilles verdez va sauter mon chéri est ce
que tu veux que gilbert des sautes mais
tu sais quoi bon bah je vais faire aussi
non tu t'es chauffer 1 ouest je vais le
faire à temps alors eh tu sais quoi
si tu sautes si tu sautes je rajoute une
autre tu sauteras pour une autre
personne à la peau non non non tu
sauteras par la loi mais ce n'est pas
pour delphine wespiser bravo
[Applaudissements]
il sautera peau alors attention les
chéris est-ce que vous êtes prêts et kim
surtout un premier aller j'y vais mais
je suis pas bien cyrille ce jour tu me
connais on est amis je vais je faire si
tu veux pas sauter sont pas allés hier
je le fais pour l'album je fais pour toi
allez allez n'a jamais et on n'a jamais
forcer quelqu'un à sauter quelques uns
ici tu sais je sais pour sa 2ème film et
c'est bon ou non mais on doute la silice
haute
ces bons grecs comme ça mais tu te
retournes comment ils sont comme ça les
choses comme ça pas attacher des boutons
péter cbl ah ouais non sur les faits sur
le fil aux légionelles
non mille fois non
allez messieurs allez allez mon gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'eau est excellent à l'excellent bravo
mon frérot et bat des cils bestiaire
monsieur gilles verdez tu sautes pour
ayew la personne âgée suis hyper
angoisses et du dégel vertige et tout le
temps oui si tu ne veux pas sauter nager
pas moi je suis viré du butin c'est mon
rêve d'aller en laponie donc je vais
faire non mais attends il y aura
d'autres sélections faire autant n'a pas
eu lieu
j'ai sous les yeux des juges oui tu veux
pas d un petit mois sa tournée je veux
tu peux pas dire est ce que tu veux
faire une déclaration d'amour à
quelqu'un avant de sauter peut-être mais
trop c'est votre voix vous est-ce que
vous pouvez parler cyril c'est fatou que
j'aime et votre voix me fait du bien par
les jeux et surtout que de leurs mots
c'est un secours
attendent ils ne sautent pas on sera des
cours d'une voiture et est ce qui reste
une hétérosexuelle gilles oui tu veux
dire un petit mot renoue partir j'étais
terrifiée par le vide dit pas les trucs
comme ça mais moi je sais de la morale
et la fesci bien j'ai sur bull mais que
ça qu'il est mignon là et les brûlures
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
là
[Musique]
barca